مسلسل صبايا دراما رمضانيه بطابع كوميدي
وبطوله نسائيه بيتكلم عن قصه فتيات
بيعيشوا في بيت واحد وبتصير معهم احداث
ومغامرات متنوعه المسلسل بيعكس حاله
اجتماعيه ومواقف يوميه ممكن اي احد في
الحياه يتعرض لها وهذه السنه بيشارك صبايا
بموسم السادس في السباق الرمضاني ومن بين
الصبايا اللي شاركوا في اجزاءه السته
الفنان السوريه جانيه اللي كانت موجوده من
اول جزء في 2009 واستمرت مشاركتها لعام
2013 واليوم بعد عشر سنوات رجعنا نشوف جني
اسبر في شخصيتها المعروفه في المسلسل باسم
ميديا او دادو
[موسيقى]
غنيه عن التاريخ
فاجات اللي فاجات فيها جني محبيها ومتابعي
المسلسل هذه السنه هي مشاركه بنتها ساندي
في المسلسل في الجزء الخامس انتهى اوميدي
عند بنت واليوم بعد عشر سنوات بتشارك
ساندي بدور بنتها واللي بتكون مقيمه مع
ابوها في امريكا وبتيجي تعيش عند امها
وبتتعلم قوه الشخصيه وكثير من الامور من
امها والصبايا اللي معها
[موسيقى]
الله
من ايدك بقى ركزي شوي فكري
غير صبايا سته بتطل علينا جني اصبر في
الموسم الرابع للموسم الكوميدي جلطه كبرت
العيله اللي له اربع مواسم رمضانيه بطوله
كل من الفنان زهير النبواني وامل الدباس
وكانت جاني شاركت في الموسم الثاني كمان
مسلسل اللي بيتكلم عن مواقف يوميه بتصير
بين الاسره الواحده وبين الجيران
وتنضم الينا من اللاذقيه النجمه جني اسبر
اهلا فيكي معانا يا جنى وكل عام وانت بالف
خير ومتالقه دائما
مساء الخير وكل عام وانتم بخير ورمضان
كريم على الجميع يا رب علينا وعليك يا رب
جنين يعني الواحد لما يفكر انه خلص يعني
كان في مرحله معينه وصبايا وحقق نجاح وكذا
ايش اللي اغراكي انك ترجعي تعودي لهذا
العمل بعد كل هذه السنوات من التوقف
هلا بصراحه
لاول شي لاغاني انه الناس ضلت كل هالسنوات
اللي نحن انقطعنا في عن تصوير مسلسل صبايا
انه ضلك عم تتفرج بهذا المسلسل على هذا
المسلسل وكانه نحن صورناه هلا
فمسلسل يعني حتى الجيل الجديد كلهم
بيعرفوه لانه ضلو عم يتفرجوا عليه وبصراحه
في محطات كثيره كانت عم تعيدوا كانوا عم
يشوفوا مقاطع كتير على اليوتيوب فشخصيه
ميديا حتى بالجيل الجديد يعني من جيل بنتي
بيعرفوها لانه هم كانوا عم يتفرجوا على
مسلسل صبايا وفي كثير ناس كانت طالب بهذه
الشخصيه
والصراحه اكثر من هيك انه انا بحس المسلسل
اللي بيشوفوته كل هالقد اثرت بالناس
بيحبوا يكون الناس انه يعتبروا شو شو يصير
بهالشخوص بعد هالمده الطويله يعني الناس
تشتاق شخصيات هم اللي بيحبوها بصراحه
هاي الذاكره الحلوه لهذه الشخصيات
ذكرتي بنتك هي مشاركه معاكي الان في
المسلسل هل هي بدايه يعني طريق حيكون في
التمثيل ولا مجرد كذا صدفه
لا لا ابدا يعني هلا بكير كتير على
موضوعنا نحن نحط خطه للمستقبل بس انا حكيت
انه انا ما انه الولد يكون عنده هوايات وي
قوي الشهور قدام الكاميرا او على المسرح
انا كثير مع لانه هذا الشيء اللي اول
شخصيته
انه يتعامل مع الناس يقدر يحكي قدام
الكاميرا
صراحه لانه ساندي اول ما خلقت ما كان
عمرها يعني شهر وشوي الوقت مثلت معي بمشهد
بمسلسل صبايا بالجزء الخامس وهي كان مشهد
لساندي
فحبيت انهم يعني هذا الموضوع عليها انه شو
رايك بتمثلي هي الشخصيه انه بالمسلسل
قوليلي اول ما خلقانه
تفاجات بكمل التفاؤل وقت اقترحت عليه هذا
الموضوع
وانا مبسوطه انه هي خالد هي التجربه بكل
ثقه وحبيت يعني انه هي كاميرا كانت يعني
كثير طبيعيه يعني
مع الكاميرا يعني
جني بس اكيد كمان يعني انت ذكرتي انه
العوده الناس حابه تعرف ايش صارت في هذه
الشخصيات بس كثير ناس وصلتك حتى انه كانوا
بيعترضوا انه انتم الان يعني خلينا نقول
في مرحله عمريه مختلفه عن وقت ما بدات
المسلسل وما الى ذلك فبيقولوا انه كان
لازم مثلا تغيروا الاسم من صبايا وما الى
ذلك وحتى اعتقد وصل الموضوع لدرجه التنمر
في التعليقات
صحيح انا اتفق معك هذه حكمه اليوم احنا
صبايا للابد
بعمر بس العشرين
هي اول شيء بالحياه
هلا هو مسلسل الصبايا ونحن وقت حكينا
بموضوع انه يكون في جيل جديد من الصبايا
هن الصبايا يعني للشبايل عشرينات اشتركوا
معنا مو معقول احنا بس لانه والله نحن
كبرنا بالعمر ما هو نحن عم نحكي عن اجيال
او عن جيل الجديد يعني
اذا اسم المسلسل صبايا فمو ضروري يعني
اللي يكون من الكومبارس للنجم الاول كلنا
بالعشرينات
يعني اليوم الجزء السادس
طيب اذا يعني خليني برضو اكون معك في هذا
الموضوع انه يعني وصل الموضوع في تعليقات
للتنمر والكلام هذا كله وفي تعليقات على
موضوع العمر والشكل والعمليات وما الى ذلك
انت ما شاء الله عليك جني ما بتخافي تردي
يعني في كثير فنانين على السوشيال ميديا
بطنشه انت بتردي وبتردي لهدوء ردود لاذعه
ليش
لا هي الفكره انه مو انه انا
بصراحه
الموضوع لموضوع التنمر وموضوع انه نحن
بدنا
ننزع نهاره لهالمبوسه او نحنا بدنا نثبت
انه انه سيء او كممثل مثلا انه
نتمسخر او بدافع الحقد فاكيد انا برد يعني
اليوم
انه وقت يتنمر حدا على
عرضي بتنمر حدا على شكلي بتنمر حدا على
بنتي اكيد انا بدي رد وانا بدي رد بمط
وبدي رد به بحق يعني اليوم فنان له الرد
مو معناتها انه انا اذا فنان فانا سوري ما
عندي مشاعر ولا احاسيس
مثلا اليوم صاحيه عندك مشاكل ممكن يعني
الشيء هذا يزيد من همومك او ما الى ذلك بس
خليني بس اقول في عندك انت وحده قالت لك
انه دكتورك يبدو هو نفس دكتور هيفاء وهبي
علقت على صوره لك في انستقرام انت رديتي
عليها وقلتي لها جربي نفس الدكتور شوفي
اذا بتطلعي تشبهينا يعني يعني كانك في كل
الاحوال بتقولي يعني ايش انه انا وهيفاء
وهبي اذا حلوين واحنا بنروح عند دكاتره
فنحن لانه الاساس حلو يعني
هلا هي بصراحه لانك انه ان كانت النجمه
هيفاء وهبي ولا كتير
من الفنان بموضوع التجميل
اي شخص واي صبيه نحن نلاقي بيكون عمري 20
سنه عم تعمل تجميل لانه اليوم
الشيء اليوم طبيعي بتلاقي انه احنا نشوف
الصبيه اللي ما بتهتم بحالها موجود وهي
موضه اساسا هلا انا مع التجميل شخص يكون
بوعي وعنده شي هو مزعوج منه انه
بس انه انا كفنانه انه كل شوي لاقي تعليق
وتنمر على موضوع التجميل ولو كل الناس
العاديه ستات البيوت اللي هي ما بتطلع
الشاشه واللي ما هي الناس اللي بيشوفوها
كل وقتهم بتعمل تجميل فليش فليش انتم عم
تتنمروا على ممثله وفنانه لازم تكون دائما
الترند بالموت بازياء وبالشكل طيب جاني
بدي احط لك صوره بما انك انت مرتاحه مع
الموضوع وعندك صراحه جدا في هذا الموضوع
وفي تغيرات الشكل والعمليات في صوره لك من
الاجزاء المختلفه من صبايا اذا نشوفها
الان الان لما تشوفي حالك جاني بتشوفي
حالك احلى بتقولي والله لا كانت في مرحله
ثانيه احلى هل عندك اي ندم على اي شيء
هلا الصراحه مو قصه احلى يمكن بهذيك
الفتره والحقيقه كان البال مرتاح اكثر كنا
بوضع كان كنا ببلد كتير
منيحه وكثير مبسوطين يعني الحياه مختلفه
بصراحه نفسيا انا بقول لك ايه انا كتير
متغيره يعني اكيد الازمات اللي مرقنا فيها
خلال عشر سنين اكيد
طبيعي الانسان يتغير وطبيعي الموضه تتغير
في ناس بتشوفني قبل احلا في ناس بتشوفني
هلا ممكن على الموضه اكثر لانه هلا صار
بيختلف يعني بس انا هاي الحلوه وقت انا
بكون مرتاحه من جوا بصراحه اكيد هديك
الفكره
اذا بدي اسالك عن الاعمال المشتركه ليش ما
بنشوف جني اسبر في الاعمال المشتركه هل هي
مثلا عليها حرب معينه هل هي مظلومه دراميا
مثلا
هلا ليكي ما قصه انه انا مظلومه لا انا
ماني مظلومه
بس هي فرص الشركات هلا ممكن نحن عم نشوف
الاعمال المشتركه اغلبها موجوده
[موسيقى]
عملت مسلسل مشترك خليجي سوري مصري اسمها
بنادم كمان انعرضت على
يمكن ما كتير الناس يعني شاقتها يعني او
محطاته مشفره مسلسل
جلطه اللي هو مسلسل مشترك اردني سوري
بس مثل ما قلت لك في يعني شركات معينه
ممكن انا للاسف طبعا اكيد بتمنى اشتغل معه
بس ما صار فرصه اني اشتغل معهم فيمكن مشان
هيك العالم ما شافتني بهذا العمل بس ان
شاء الله لقدام
طيب نحن بنتمنى لك دائما التوفيق جاني
وانا يعني حبيت اليوم الكلام معاكي لانه
صراحه عندك شفافيه وراحه مع نفسك جميله
جدا يعني يا ريت كلنا تكون عندنا هذه
الراحه وفعلا كلنا صبايا في اي عمر ما
نخلي احد لازم ياثر علينا بنشكرك كانت
معنا من اللاذقيه النجمه الجاني اسبر شكرا
لك